gerne und wir können eigentlich direkt
weiter machen denn es geht wieder um
wahlkampf und wieder darum wie
langweilig er ist und ich als head of
social media der funk zentralredaktion
weiß natürlich über social media im
wahlkampf und mir ist einfach
aufgefallen dass es da auch extrem
langweilig ist es ist zum teil
hochgradig unprofessionell menschen die
in den bundestag wollen und überhaupt
kein social media profile haben und ich
frage mich gerade in pandemie zeiten wo
es so große potenziale gibt in den
sozialen medien warum werden die nicht
genutzt warum nach zehn jahren in den
social media schon thema ist hat die
politik immer noch nicht verstanden dass
sie da sein muss und dass sie das auch
richtig nutzen muss verstehen nicht ja
also ich wusste dezent dagegen
ist eigentlich politiker noch
sympathisch die sich da nicht für
ausgaben in den social media weil wir in
den letzten jahren ich beobachte das
einen overkill im social-media-bereich
frank witter und twitter definiere ich
ja als direkt kommunikation vom bauch
über den zeigefinger in sein die unter
ausschaltung des hirns und wir haben
dadurch sehr viele so twitter-meldungen
und politiker die wie teenager herum
twittern zumindest in der schweiz ich
sehe es aber auch in deutschland für
mich ist das jetzt eigentlich eine gute
nachricht
der letzte funke seriosität dass der
hier bewiesen wird dass ich diese leute
wenigstens auf social media zurückkaufen
also machen wir jetzt dieses social
media den man überschätzt also erstmal
werde ich ganz wenig von twitter weil
twitter ist wirklich ein jumbo genießen
es war so schlechte laune macht aber
sie war die präsidentin die über twitter
regiert und
mache politik endlich ganz oder listen
im journalisten ja gut aber mir geht es
jetzt darum junge menschen erreichen und
es dann gar nicht mehr nur die jungen
ich meine facebook wird mittlerweile ab
30 aufwärts bis 60 70 genutzt also es
geht mir jetzt auch nicht nur um die
jungen zielgruppe nur facebook noch jung
ich glaube eben genau also ab 30 so
allen instagram und dann kommt natürlich
auch tik tok ja
ich finde da ist zu wenig nehmen wir mal
die kanzlerkandidaten und die
kanzlerkandidatin kanzlerkandidaten
annalena baerbock hat ich glaube 200
noch was 1000 sondern 70.000 ja also
fast 300 tausend follower bei instagram
nehmen wir dass man jetzt die macht es
gut die anderen zwei entschuldigungen
führen
aber was aber was reizt sie denn fragt
und ich möchte wirklich wissen was macht
sie gut ich muss zugeben ich habe mich
in vorbereitung auf die sendung habe ich
mir alle drei mal angeschaut was ich
unerträglich finde sie machen es ja noch
nicht mal selber dann macht es doch
bitte selber dann nutzt die gelegenheit
nehmt uns wähler potenziellen wähler mit
und lasst uns teilhaben an eurem leben
ja kriegt annalena baerbock auch mal
morgens der post nun wenn sie john
kornblum das zitat ist über olaf scholz
das will ich doch sehen ich möchte nicht
auf dem handy dann einfach hier auch
noch weiter wahlplakate haben auch weg
in die redaktion habe ich annalena
baerbock olaf scholz und linde noch wie
sie alle heißen schon 174 tausend mal
gesehen das brauche ich nicht ich möchte
dann mitgenommen werden und da kann
gerne eine professionelle agentur das
unterstützen aber ich möchte dass sie es
selber machen diese werbeplattform
instagram furchtbar nächste mich weg zum
großen wieder wie entscheidend aber was
glaubst du wie entscheidend ist die
präsenz auf instagram die präsenz bei
twitter ist das wahl entscheiden oder
ist das einfach nur so ein bisschen
ratespiele hat zu einem nicht hat mir
alle social media accounts angeguckt wie
die follower zeit fein säuberlich
aufgeschrieben und hinter werbung ist
christian linder mit 247.000 scholz ist
abgeschlagen mit 44.100 instagram
follower nehmen wenn man installieren
scholz ist trotz den umfragen auf 1 wo
ich aber genau bei amelie bin ist die
jugend natürlich hat die welt natürlich
auch spät haben anders und bei den
jungen sind ja die grünen weit vorn und
annalena baerbock ist mit 72.000 auf
instagram nicht schlecht ich glaube es
ist ein tool aber ich glaube die ganze
welt überschätzt social media ich habe
auch ein buch damals geschrieben ein
foto wie entwicklung unser leben
zerstört und ich bin immer noch der
überzeugung ist wird social media ein
viel viel viel zu großer teil zugewiesen
war auch jahren gar nicht 100 prozent
genau ist wird sich weg entwickeln und
wenn man es jetzt nicht im blick hat es
ist einfach keine nachhaltige politik es
wird immer wichtiger klar jetzt die
große wählerschaft die so alt
und zum selbst sehe ich ganz genauso das
ist ja das was ich auch kritisiere es
ist unauthentisch sind presse
mitteilungen oder fotos fertig hier
jetzt habe ich auch mein treffen was für
die versteigerung ist sie müssen ihr
team richtig an weisen sie brauchen
professionelle leute und nicht denken
heiko maas schon in der diskussion aber
instagram lese wird überwiegend von
meinem team gemacht also was ist der
gmbh und machst oder was es nicht ist
aber was ist dann genau der nutzen also
wenn ich folge man kann ja auch babys
beauty place volk und das ist alles
unklar und dann wir wollen gar kein gar
nicht weiter darüber reden da habe ich
ein gutes gefühl für mich aufgehoben und
freue mich über jeden neuen ehrenbürger
was auch immer aber was habe ich davon
wenn ich olaf scholz folge leider genau
das muss er ja beantworten also wir alle
wissen es wird ganz viel nach sympathie
entschieden ja kriegt man ja einfach mit
und ich glaube da kann man nirgendwo
sonst kann man so gut sympathie aufbauen
wie wenn man social media haben das
nicht aber es ist
ein blend werden dann muss das nicht
gemacht hat wie das ganze jahr gehabt zu
sagen die politiker verbringen zum teil
so viel zeit mit irgendwelchen tippen
von nachrichten
es gab mal gab an dass er ein magazin
das hat mal ausgerechnet gab politiker
die twittern quasi jede jede stunde am
tag also wenn die 24 teams am tag machen
sie werde ich die ganze zeit wach sein
dann machen sie also
2000 keine retweets mit dabei da frage
ich mich wenn sitzungswochen sind wenn
das ministerin und minister sind was
machen die eigentlich war ich muss ja
auch mal in ein gespräch ich muss auch
meine akte richtig lesen da muss ich
mich fern mal zwei stunden richtig gut
sein also wie soll das funktionieren
aber das problem ist jedoch wenn man
sich dazu gehört was ihr sagt das
problem ist doch grundsätzlich wenn man
nichts zu sagen hat als politiker dann
nützt es auch nichts wenn du den ganzen
tag gab social media aber das problem
dass wir in der deutschen politik
glauben ich kann das etwas
außenstehender wirklich gut beurteilen
weil ich beobachte das mit der nötigen
distanz die euch natürlich fehlt dann
sehe ich einfach dass die deutsche
politik ein akutes eine gute substanz
probleme wir haben ein botschafts
problem und bei diesen tschuldigung
langweilen die da zugang ist wünsche ich
mir jetzt nicht dass sie ihre langeweile
auch noch auf social media verbreiten
und das was sie empfinden ist für mich
eben ausdruck dieses substanz problems
die haben nichts interessantes mit 28
das ist doch das ja dann doch die ganze
nation treffen bürgerinnen und bürger
die erleben hier muss man gerade im
wahlkampf so viel was auch interessant
ist für die menschen mit zu bekommen um
auch nähe zur politik wäre wir
beschweren uns denn
politik ist der politik ist es nicht
einfach das nun ein foto macht von sich
mit den wählen wo man ihm lauernden der
politik das sind ernste auf die fragen
das sind dass sie ganz wichtige
weichenstellung sieht man mache ich
nicht nicht und wenn man natürlich auch
noch quasi dieses instagram und diese
dinge einfach als zur selbstinszenierung
der eigenen heimlichkeit beweist dass
man social media immer wenn grobe
vorstellungen sieht man deutlich die
leute mitnehmen ich bin interessant ich
habe alle kandidatinnen und kandidaten
für unseren tik tok kanal interviewt und
ich habe einfach also kanzler kann jeder
einen kandidaten ja mal richtig respekt
und ich finde einfach jemand der ein
land regieren will kann noch nicht angst
haben da jetzt irgendwie im internet zu
landen er wirklich alle so nervösen als
horst interviews 100 post was ist für
dich ein gutes ohne dass sich jemand um
nah aber zeigt dass ich das gefühl habe
ich bin als mensch das fand ich erst mal
richtig was kali gesagt hat und für
politik begeistert diese
politikverdrossenheit ich glaube dass
wir die auf social media total gut auf
ihn kennt denkt was ist das wichtigere
beide politiker dass herrn aber ist oder
dass er gute politik natürlich
lieber der einfachen gute politik aus
meiner sicht gute politik für das land
macht der märz die halter ersten social
account hat leider ihre arbeit aber ich
habe also ich muss ja insofern natürlich
am liebsten unterstützen weil was sagen
wir denn wir sagen geht die sind alle
drei langen waren aber ein wunder celina
der un social account hat ist nicht so
gut wie im bundestrend erfolgreich sein
aber es ist
trotzdem super team aber es bringt doch
nichts davon abgesehen hat
also wir machen das ergebnis zählt doch
am ende ja natürlich am 10 das ding ist
nur und das erwarte ich ehrlicherweise
auch in der heutigen welt von
spitzenpolitikern ich möchte auch was
wir den menschen erfahren nicht nur über
140 seiten langes dossier im stadtteil
merken wir eigentlich was da passiert
aber was passiert denn da aber auch
social media wie wenn man ein gesagt wir
werden ein gesagt wenn du auch sagte
twitter ist eigentlich eine blase nur
auf social media instagram mit schönen
fotos und hier lächelt er oder lächelt
sie und dann noch ein bisschen das
pferdchen streicheln und den hund
ausführen ich glaube ja wunderbar
anderen nein aber ich hab mein sondern
der dafür zu tun dass wir ein wenig das
schimmelproblem beispielsweise bei der
rente haben über das thema wird noch auf
social media gar nicht diskutiert ich
kenne kein instagram poster sagt oh gott
herr ja auch immer mit einer armen alten
rentnerin im arm sagt er diese frau hat
nur noch 800 euro und ich trete an um
diese die die rentnerin zu helfen es
gibt zwar ist aber das problem versuchen
ja instagram genau da eben doch mit
diesen botschaften zu bestücken indem
sie wahlplakate
das braucht kein mensch wenn und das ist
ja unser punkt glaube ich da sind wir
uns alle einig wenn sie instagram
richtig benutzen nämlich authentisch
benutzen kann es ihnen helfen weil die
menschen sie kennenlernen diese drei
langweiler so bringt es gar nichts
werbebotschaft auf dem handy brauchen
habe ich auf der straße oder im fokus
stehen also ich bin der
underdog aber inhalte absolut richtig
und ich muss möchte ich bin letzte an
den wahlplakaten lang gefahren es ist ja
wie instagram 0 2
mm drauf und ich hätte da wo ist denn
die botschaft
[Musik]